Development can be rough in a VTuber agency and yellow was no different.
I knew from the beginning I wanted a hypnosis theme and it took quite a few
attempts to become the cuttlefish you know and recognize today.
Yes you are allowed to laugh, this was literally my first draft.
I quickly was developed to be a cuttlefish early on but I took a very splatoonly
vape which wasn't quite what I wanted.
Then from this outline you can actually see my shape and pupils are already in place
which is amazing.
Then a big switch-up happened and I was drawn in a yukata with permanent swirl eyes
which was later changed into my classic cuttlefish pupil eyes.
Then finally we arrived at my pearlescent design and I am none other than
Strony Cuttles at your service.